hey kristen hey annabeth hi
hey i have to tell you i love both your
characters so much so look i'm a huge
mike flanagan fan but i watched this
series in two days i was
hooked from beginning to end like wow i
want to know before we get into
characters in the story had you guys
seen haunting of hill house in blind
manor kristin
well um i had not before i was hired but
i quickly
binged everything so that i could um fit
into the flanking world
um and annabeth of course has been was
in um right haunting house yeah go ahead
and annabeth oh no no i i um
yes
anything that mike's done i've watched
uh
with fascination because i think he's
he's amazing
and you know when it comes to fans now
of my planning and you know there's this
expectation of these fabulous characters
you know these moments that really
really freak you out what are you
excited for them to see when it comes to
midnight mass
hmm
kristen you go
please um
well the thing is is that the thing
about midnight mass that's so incredible
is that it was created by directed by
written by and edited by mike flanagan
so
it is such an incredible beautiful
example
of of his creative gift so just it
really does feel like to be able to be
part of something that is
such a total comprehensive vision
um
i just want people to experience from
top to tail i want i just want them to
dig into this sumptuous feast that
they're about to
receive on the 24th i really do feel
that way i feel like every moment has
been carefully crafted and it is
absolutely intentional so when you know
that and the person who made it it's got
such high ambitions i just want
everybody to experience it yeah and
about when you get the call from mike
being like i'm working on this new
series are you just in immediately i i i
i sound um like a cheap date but yes i i
i very much um i trust him
i
when he asked me to play sarah gunning i
said yes i'd unseen
and again i think
you know only because he does deliver
this
in the genre of horror this deep
psychological character investigation
that somehow just elevates um
i don't know our humanity and some you
know it's a crazy admixture because you
think like okay it's just a horror show
i know there's something that's like
very surgical and very meaningful so
always
you become so invested in these
characters too and so is it safe to say
that
no one is safe on this island
um i think this is great to say this is
a standalone series
um you know so much happens on this
island you first get into this island
looks like a beautiful place to live
obviously people in this town have gone
through a hard time
and then things go downhill very quickly
so i've been asking the cast how would
you personally handle the events on this
island are you gonna try baby hero and
save the day or are you jumping on the
boat as quickly as you can to get out of
there
oh i would have been on out of there
there's no
the minute there were like dead cats on
the beach
um so hamish tried to convince me that
he'd be the hero that he thinks
he'd save everyone you guys agree with
that
um i'm kind of in love with him as a
human being
i think he's he would
you do
i mean when he turns around and says
everyone with me i am with him when i'm
in the store i'm with him that's amazing
well obviously you know father paul
plays
this charismatic character especially
when we're first introduced to him what
do you think
father paul does for the people in this
town when he first arrives on the island
i mean i think he
reinspires them with faith
and hope
you know i mean i my character certainly
doesn't want to drink the kool-aid but
you can speak more i mean you know
the devout one can
speak i feel like he um
he humanizes their struggles
and because of where he comes from
um he knows them in ways that they can't
put their finger on but they feel seen
and then he capitalizes on it with the
very fact that he's in a position of
power and of knowledge and all of that
and then he you know
it becomes um i think it's very deep
because of where he comes from that's a
it's a i mean he's like a
savior and yes a savior and um
a villain as well you know yeah
so well said without saying anything
guys such a pleasure getting to talk to
both you um yeah two days in and i was
like oh my god this series
oh thank you so much
yeah congratulations thank you thank you
thanks morgan bye
you